good morning afternoon evening as the
case may be
i'm bill litton from suny downstate at
state university of new york in brooklyn
and kings county hospital
and i'm presenting today
on can multi-scale computer modeling
save the human genome project and that's
subtitled climbing the ohms of
schizophrenia
so the human genome project
perhaps is
not really need saving but it in some
sense
did not live up to the hyperbole
assigned to it so the hope was you map
the genome
you understand disease
and you cure disease
and this hope probably came from the
known monogenic diseases such as sickle
cell
or cystic fibrosis where you have a
single gene altering
a single protein
altering
the entire
phenome
and the pathophysiology of the person
causing disease
so it was hoped and perhaps even assumed
that
common diseases would also reflect clear
genetics probably not monogenic but
maybe die or trigenic and would then
give us a handle on how to treat these
common diseases and these common
diseases would include
diabetes type 1 or type 2 or other
subtypes that may exist that are not
well defined
and hypertension of which there are a
number of subtypes and schizophrenia
which also has multiple subtypes and
enormous complexity and we'll be talking
today about schizophrenia
so schizophrenia like
many of these diseases
has no clear inheritance pattern it has
a combination of genetic underpinnings
and of
aspects of the disease that clearly have
responded to nurture and not nature in
terms of the person's experience
so what causes these common diseases
it's not purely inheritance it's complex
it's
multifactorial and it requires
multi-factorial approaches so here on
the bottom
just for
entertainment value we have the kind of
genome that we need to look at right
this is a little snippet of a genome of
something or someone or what is it of
course you cannot tell
it is a papaya not even a person at all
[Applause]
so
what
we have set out to do in our lab is to
climb the ohms
and
then link omics with clinical clinical
semiology and that's the word like
semiotics of signs although in
clinical talk that includes both
symptoms which are things reported by
the patient or in the case of
schizophrenia more often reported by the
patient's family and signs and that's
what you observe as a doctor when you
see the patient
and we link all this with our
multi-scale mod computer modeling which
is abbreviated msm and which has been
strongly supported by grace peng and by
the interagency modeling analysis group
multi-scale modeling initiative
and a number of grant projects some
funded via brain
so
we want to understand how does the
genome which in this case is primarily
the
main chromosomal genome of the person
but in some cases it may include the
microbiome a tumor home a firearm
the mitochondrial genome etc
it influence disease across levels of
semiotics semiology
and we go via the what's called the
varium which is mostly identified
through looking at single nucleotide
polymorphisms little switches of
individual
nucleotides a t g or c which are
markers in the genome and they're not
necessarily and often are not directly
inside a gene of interest but are near
enough that they co-localize with the
gene of interest
there's also epigenome we need to
understand probably something about the
proteome and certainly what's called the
phenome and neuroscience we also need to
consider the connecto and we also
in neuroscience want to consider
behavior when i consider cognition i
want to consider these uh things which
don't have old names yet although no
doubt they soon will
so the clinical semiology of
schizophrenia is complex molecular level
known changes involve dopamine and
glutamate neurotransmitters there are
dendritic changes which include synaptic
pruning there are certainly changes
during development and in fact the
disease only manifests in typically late
adolescence early adulthood and so the
developmental anomalies are important uh
circuit anomalies apoptosis death of
cells which is natural because you do a
lot of pruning in development but here
there's some pruning going awry probably
areas of the brain the prefrontal cortex
and hippocampus and the interlinks
between them being particularly
implicated changes in the
electroencephalogram changes in gamma
and theta which uh particularly gamma
has been demonstrated clinically and i
say changes because sometimes it's up
sometimes it's down we'll be focused on
a case where in the animal model which
we have
modeled
simulated we see
high gamma and low higher gamma lower
theta and then the remarkable and awful
frankly thought disorder that patients
have with this disease which you would
think would not be amenable to modeling
simulation uh it is not directly
available but we have a trick for doing
that and looking at that using shannon
information theory
so we use multi-scale modeling
and
the scales here shown on the x-axis
of
time which go from millisecond
or sub millisecond of molecular
for uh deformation such as the sodium
channel change that leads to the spike
or action potential which takes a
millisecond
up to
years if you talk about development
certainly not something we can currently
simulate except in a very
uh high level manner then here on the
y-axis we have space down to molecular
angstrom nanometer level and up to the
entire brain systems motor system visual
system
limbic system all working together uh
and then above that at a level that can
be measured in time by things like
reaction time but cannot be assigned a
spatial
scale cognition behavior information
so
we want to link clinical semiology
multiple levels
the ohms multiple level from genome to
phenome
and our multi-scale modeling where in
this case we're going to be focused on
area ca3
of the
hippocampus and we're going to look at
how
interactions from the molecular level
up to
the circuit level
change
the way
the circuit behaves in terms of dynamics
and in terms of information flow i also
want to point out that
what we've circled here we have
intersecting scales so in some organ
systems you can say okay the cell does
this and now we'll simplify the cell and
we'll embed it in a network of cells
such as the liver network of cells it's
very important in metabolism
but in the brain i think the separation
of scales is very difficult in some
cases impossible because these cells are
enormous and they go through multiple
layers in the hippocampus layers include
stratamore center for avidalia stratton
radio atom and the cortex the layers are
well known as layer one through layer
six
but
these cells are so big they are sampling
from different parts of the network so
the cells themselves
behave uh in ways that are determined by
the network and then of course the
network is made up of cells behaves in
ways that are determined by the cell so
there's not a clean separation
so the story starts as
fairy tales must with demonic possession
uh the film the exorcist came out a
number of years ago and it depicts
what is now thought to almost certainly
be a case of nmda receptor antibody
disease
the film of course was highly
fictionalized but it was based on a true
story that a child was a boy rather than
a girl
the
key findings which are depicted in the
movie are severe dystonia
twisting not to the point of being able
to turn your head all the way around but
almost
and um
psychosis which is the point that
interests us and where we have this
intersection between schizophrenia and
uh this particular nmda disease as well
as with ketamine which is a drug that
blocks nmda and nmda antagonists the
nmda antibodies block
the nmda
at the psychosis being very prominent in
this disorder and autonomic dysfunction
which was also seen in that job has been
documented in many cases since that also
of importance clinically is that these
kids often kids well sometimes kids and
less pregnant women women more than men
get better so whether you have a priest
or two priests or no priests at all they
generally get better and so there is a
happy ending to the exorcist
so
we are looking at a very simple in this
case hippocampal ca3 cornumonis area 3
model
and we've done modeling
over many years over a decade now
working first with modulo zarowicz who
was originally trained with lee finkel
who unfortunately died uh sami moten and
mohammad sharif and so here from our
paper is this simple model that we'll be
presenting the main feature here is the
uh
the pyramidal cells here on the right
and also
uh basket cells inhibitory cells primal
cells are excitatory cells
orions lachinosa molecular ra cells olm
cells easier to say olm
projecting to the dendrites of parallel
cells vascular cells for example basket
cells also project to themselves this is
a circuit of 1200 cells so when i show
projecting itself it's not projecting to
it's not a single cell protecting itself
it's a population projecting to that
population
connections between the inhibitory cells
all driven with a theta input from the
medial septum although we demonstrated
that that's not necessary for the action
of this network so the network works
without any external input
once it's activated to is sufficiently
to to to go
um
so we now are interested in what does
this network do
and we find as many have found within
this type of network and in cortical
networks that the classically defined
eeg
oscillations such as theta which in the
human would be
four to eight
and the mouse would be faster and gamma
which is
low gam and high gamma but let's say
around 40 hertz is kind of classic gamma
these emerge from the network based on
the connectivity and based on the time
constants and complex interactions
of multiple ion channels in the
individual cells and i've noticed that
these individual cells are not
integrating fire cells they have
complexity bestowed on them by a number
of potassium channels calcium channels
the fast sodium which allows for spiking
as well as importantly the anomalous
rectifier or ih
which comes from the hcng
so here we see emergence we're looking
here on the x-axis at time we have a
raster plot on the bottom which shows
the spiking of individual cells the
pyramidal cells in red basket cells and
green
olm cells in blue we can generate a
simulated lfp local field potential here
at the top we have the scale bar here
and
we see in the spectrogram here across
different frequencies that we have a
peak at theta and a smaller
broader peak at gamma
so we now
identify the type of dynamics that are
occurring and these have been well
characterized by nancy cappell roger
traub and their colleagues and these
include what's called pain
parameter interneuron network gamma and
what's called ing
interneuron network gamma so here at the
bottom is the gap
um the interneuron network of basket
cells
causing a gamma without respect to the
pyramidal cells and here at the top is
the ping
again producing a gamma but using both
the primal cells and the internal rounds
to do it
we now jump back to schizophrenic and
we're to keep trying to
involve our understanding of the omics
the clinical semiology
and
the multi-scale modeling and in this
case we're dealing with the
genomics and a very prominent important
paper published in nature 2011
showed
a number of snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms identifying the very own
of schizophrenia across many many
patients that's one of the difficulties
with this many many patients
undoubtedly include many subtypes of
schizophrenia in any case the usual
suspect came up usual suspects
the nmda
came up in the form of a single nuclear
polymorphism that is near to the grin to
a
specific type of
nmda receptor
also implicated was gaba a and hcn
in looking at snips that were near
uh particular genes that are known have
a known product of course many of the
snips are not near anything with a known
product or maybe in non-coding regions
that's something we don't deal with we
clearly do not deal with 108 of them uh
that were identified we're dealing with
these three
just looking at
the
nmda
we can then use our results
to make a prediction and that is a
prediction that the grin to a transcript
would be reduced specifically in the
orients lacking ozone molecular olm
cells
and so here we're looking at the effects
of nmda blockade
in our simulation on either oml cells or
basket cells or pyramidal cells
and
what we find is uniquely when you block
the olm cells
uh here we see a raster plot on the
right raster at the top
lfp at the bottom local field potential
different types of cells again pyramidal
cells vascular cells oil cells
when we do this blockage at this
specific site and not other sites we get
this great increase in gamma frequency
reduction and theta frequency and that
was the signature we were looking at
based on ketamine
model animal model
of schizophrenia of psychosis really not
schizophrenia of psychosis and so here
we see theta change
theta down gamma up with olm different
patterns with basket are parallel
different patterns with combinations of
locations so this enables us to make a
transcriptome transcriptomic prediction
based on our multi-scale modeling
understanding of dynamics
and based on what have been shown in
genome-wide association study genomics
of schizophrenia
now we go on to think about
a somewhat more complex model
incorporating these other two locations
uh this model was relatively recently
published in npj schizophrenia
we now incorporate not only the nmda
changes and we hear a lot more
types of parameters such as sodium
channel density blade rectifier density
then we're illustrating but we're just
demonstrating where we're making changes
the place we make changes are nmda in
various locations but now again focused
based on our earlier finding
on the olm site as well as gaba a
changes and ih changes and what we're
interested in now
is really jumping from what we've been
looking at at the scale of
molecules in the sense that we are
talking about blockade of specific
receptors which are molecules of denim d
a
the scale of cells in that we're
actually
generating models that
incorporate the details of cellular
uh
ion channels in the dendrites in the
soma
and look at
how the dynamics occur through that
interaction as well as through the
interaction of the network
and produce the local field potential
which is up here in the whole
hippocampus let's say although really
we're looking at ca3 now we're going to
make this jump from these levels all the
way up to what we can understand of
cognition and behavior which is of
course
the dramatic alteration and the
life-altering life
destroying in some cases alteration
seen in schizophrenia the paranoia or
hallucinations dissociations lack of
ability
to think nowadays the cognitive core is
thought to be the
primary anomaly of schizophrenia that
leads to positive what's called positive
and negative symptoms
so how are we going to do that we're
going to turn to information theory
and we
have used a tool called
normalized transfer entropy abbreviated
nte
to identify information flow through and
this is a simple model
of just excitatory cells in red
inhibitory cells in blue these are
integrated fire cells they're not uh
detailed realistic cells in any way but
we just want to use this to demonstrate
that we can have from this left
hemisphere as it were to this right
hemisphere projections in one direction
only and as as little as let's say two
percent
of projection density
fairly small projection density we can
start to clearly identify
which direction the projection is going
using information theory and
many people will not need to be reminded
but i will remind that information
theory is based on statistical analysis
and so you say what is the
probability at some level uh or in this
case a
transfer entropy normalized transfer
entropy that there is information flow
from this
what place to this place so if we have
low enough
density uh just above zero percent uh
density of connections in one direction
we can't say are we going one way or are
we going the other the blue
here is the same as the red uh left to
right it's the same as right to left
uh apologies for using the same colors
the colors here don't really apply the
colors on the right here
so uh once we get up to there's two
percent we can clearly identify it so we
can use this tool
we go back
to our ca3 network and we do use this
tool to
identify
the normalized transfer entropy
in
the case of
our modified model with either nmda
alterations gaba a alterations or ih
alterations
uh and
we pick out in this case four different
points with different degrees of
alterations different degrees what we
regard as
simulated schizophrenia pathology
pathophysiology in this ca3 network and
we find that at in a case where the
oscillatory strength is overall very
low and so here
the oscillatory strength is on the
y-axis and this l1 is just a label
referring to this case we have very
little power
in oscillation and we also have very
little
information flow
when we go to another extreme where we
have a very high very
strict oscillatory control of the
network and the network here in the
raster plot is primarily the going to be
the pyramidal cells that's the largest
population 800 of the 1200 cells
we have very high power of oscillation
and again very low information flow here
shown in red comparable to what we saw
there
it's only in the intermediate cases
shown here as h1h2
where with intermediate level of
oscillatory strength shown here in the
black histogram bars we have the higher
amount of information flow
from the input to the network to the
output to the network so we hypothesize
that
there are a set of controls
through the different
aspects of
neurodynamics both cellular which would
be the hcn or ih it's purely a cellular
phenomenon an ion channel
voltage-sensitive ion channel
and synaptic nmda
and gaba-a that are controlling
these aspects
together the aspect of oscillatory
strength and the aspect of information
flew through
and this point i want to emphasize often
we look at these
neuronal networks and we look at actual
recordings from
classically you and weasel from cats or
from macaques nowadays or mice and rats
and we say the cell is firing a lot
therefore there's a lot of information
there and we would postulate at least in
the system that that's not the case so
here firing rate in the left panel on
the x-axis
and tran normalized transfer and
frequency or information flow
in the y-axis
demonstrating that very fast firing
cells
do not
transmit a lot of information and in
fact when you have all the cells firing
fast you just can't distinguish much
between them of course this is
there's a lot of discussion that could
be added here but uh
the general observation is too fast or
too slow
no information or very little
information flow it's the sweet spot in
between where you have the variability
of firing where you can get information
flow through and the
this correlates very closely with the
population synchrony here shown in the
right panel x-axis is population
synchrony y-axis again normalized
transfer entropy where the color coding
shows that the same cells here and here
also again this notion of a sweet spot
where you have intermediate oscillatory
strength where you have a dramatic fall
off when you have too much synchrony and
a fall off generally although there's
exceptions
when you have too little synchrony
so both rate
and oscillation are important indicators
and i would regard both of them as
epiphenomena really these are what we
can measure
as indicators of what the coding is
that's going on in the system which is
complex multiplexed and
across many modalities as it were the
neurotransmitters of different
time constants uh we have these happy
phenomenal indicators that tell us the
coding is going on and
really to our way of thinking it does
not
really it's not really suited to just
thinking about it in terms of right we
really need to think about this
oscillatory strength and temporal coding
in this context as well
just to say that we've explored nte as
well as oscillatory strength as well as
right
in the higher dimensions of
looking at these nmda antagonism
parameters ih parameters and gaba a
parameters so here as we go across the
various panels we are changing i have to
read this gaba a scaling
is um
being changed across the panels
and on the x-axis we are changing nmda
receptor scaling and on the y-axis the
ih or acn scaling and so we find that at
certain locations in this
three-dimensional parameter space we
have these h's which are the ones i
showed before the h1 and h2 which has
extremely
high
relatively
high information flow as well as
locations here l1 with very low
oscillation and low information flow and
l2 with actually what turns out to be
high oscillation you can't see that here
but you can see that there's low
information flow so we explore this
parameter space to see what the dynamics
are to see what the information flow is
and to think about how
these various influences to the cell
into the network
influence
function
in the sense of
that information can be regarded as a
bit of a proxy for cognition
uh we want to use that to move on to
thinking about drug cocktails where
we're not just using a single drug but
using multiple drugs to control the
disease
that's as complex as this is in fact
drug cocktails typically are used
empirically multiple therapies are used
empirically for treating schizophrenia
and for treating many other diseases
including epilepsy parkinson's disease
and others uh we have made much more
complex models than what's shown here in
this here just an illustration of a
cortical model
but illustrating here on the right that
we include a lot of
molecular mechanisms in our model
including calcium which comes out of the
endoplasmic reticulum as well as in from
the outside and including cyclic amp
including a very preliminary model of g
proteins to get the complexity to look
at how drugs might act and how they
might act at the molecular level up to
the subcellular level to the cellular
level
to the network level again omics and
scales
of organization and clinical semiology
of levels of signs and symptoms
just to mention very briefly we're also
very much involved in the critical
credible practice of modeling and
simulation cpms initiative
of the interagency modeling analysis
group multi-scale modeling initiative
led by grace peng who's an author in one
of these papers and we've published a
number of papers with
rules loose rules still but we're trying
to get to a point where modeling and
simulation both in biomedicine research
and in healthcare is sufficiently
organized and
that it could be regulated by the food
and drug administration to be involved
in devices developed involved in for
example stimulation devices
for uh parkinson's disease where the
model could be part of that the
simulation could be part of that so we
have here a
publication specific to neuroscience as
well as here a broader publication with
the 10 rules
from multidisciplinary perspective
including people working in orthopedics
working in wound healing working in
multiple areas
and here at third paper which is more
just general
philosophy of simulation and modeling as
applied to biological phenomena
so thank you thank you for inviting me
and
look forward to discussing as we have
our discussion groups later